المسلسل التلفزيوني Macabre المستمر الذي يمثل
الملحمة الروسية في معركة
بومود ، الجزء الأخير من هذه الدراما هو
أن pragodzin قائد
شركة Wagner العسكرية الخاصة كما يحب أن
يطلق على نفسه منظمة المرتزقة
قد تراجع عن تهديده بسحب
بلده.  القوات من المدينة في العاشر من مايو
وتسليمها إلى الشيشان تحت
قيادة قاديروف وذلك لأنه
يقول إنه نيد تلقى الآن وعدًا
بالذخيرة التي كان يدعي حتى الآن
أن وزارة
الدفاع الروسية تنكره الآن  كل
هذا جزء من
الخلاف المستمر الغامض بينه وبين وزارة
الدفاع داخل روسيا ، حيث يشتكي كثيرًا وينتقد
علنًا
قيادة
الجنرالات الروس الذين جندهم مؤخرًا
جنرالات روس سابقين ، لكنني أعتقد أن
هذا حقًا شيء من
تشتيت الانتباه لأنه بقدر ما
يشعر الأوكرانيون بالقلق ، فقد كانوا
سعداء إذا غادرت مجموعة فاجنر وكان لابد من
استبدالها لأنها
كانت ستترك فترة من الضعف في
تلك المعركة الدموية للغاية من أجل مدينة
يقول الأوكرانيون إنهم  يسعدهم قتل
الروس ولكن بقدر ما
يشعرون بالقلق ليس لديهم أي
مصلحة أو ميزة إستراتيجية على عكس
استعداداتهم لما يقولون إنه
هجوم صيفي مخطط